so finally made a short film then didn't
I yeah if you missed it do not panic
what's the whole thing by clicking on
the thingy but now behind the scenes did
you know that the Tea chronicles is
actually based on a true story very very
loosely basically yes kyon did move into
our house he then proceeded to make me
lots of cups of tea I said Cayenne you
are making me an awful lot of tea and he
said yes I am
I think we could make a horror film out
of that now when you're writing a script
every page that you write counts for
approximately one minute of on-screen
time and when we started mankind wanted
to write a three minute YouTube sketch
so three pages however after about three
months or so of trying to write the
thing it turned out the script was 11
pages long and we both kind of liked it
so we didn't really decide to make a
short film it just sort of happened that
way after writing came planning out all
of the shots which meant bringing in
legendary YouTube cameraman
extraordinaire curator Brian if you have
ever seen a pretty-looking video on
YouTube we have a British person in it
before it is likely that you have seen
Kieran's handiwork dude gets around
usually I like to plan all of the shots
myself because I am a bit of a control
freak but this time I gave up that
control to Karen so here are all of the
shots and then we refined the shot this
together and I'm just incredibly glad
that I did that because so many of my
favorite shots in this film I wouldn't
have come up with myself they are all
the brainchild of mr. Kieran O'Brien so
protip find talented people get them to
do all of the hard work for you that's
how you make a film so total crew for
the film was about 12 people which i
think is pretty small for a short film
but was more than enough for me given
that the crew I'm used to having on set
is one the thing I think I was probably
most nervous about was trying to act and
direct at the same time ideally I would
have just directed because I think
everyone's better when they only have to
focus on one thing and also I just don't
have a massive amount of confidence in
my acting ability but um ultimately I
don't think it was a problem I think I
didn't know okay job one of the most
important things for us from the start
was to try and make the film not look
like other stuff on YouTube to make it
really distinct and like a big part of
that was production design it was like
redecorating and rearranging all of the
rooms in the house trying to make them
look as visually interesting as we
possibly could and trying to help set
the mood of the film in fact one of the
cool things that we did is after we
filmed all of the scenes in the office
we spent a day completely redecorating
that office room and turned it into the
bedroom set which so far nobody in
comments
to notice yet so that makes me very
happy I think we do get to do quite a
lot of cool stuff on set actually like
there were lots of moments where I would
just be like I can't believe that I
wrote this in the script and now it's
actually happening in front of me like
especially when I got to throw tea
directly into the lens of Kieran's 4,000
pound camera which was covered
exclusively like sandwich bags and
elastic bands and he was wearing a bin
bag it was sort of mad now there are a
fair amount of visual effects in the
film which fortunately for me meant that
I got to spend a day prancing around in
front of a green screen wearing a silly
costume I love that we've wrote this in
the scripts and that's the thing in fact
to get the shot of little teabag Charlie
hanging by a string we did genuinely
hang me from the ceiling of the green
screen studio which was incredibly
painful on my groin oh my god but it's
one of my favorite shots in the film so
I think it was worth it surprisingly I
think probably the most challenging part
of the whole process for me was the
editing because love what we got just
didn't work like it didn't fit or it
didn't look good where it wasn't funny
we just wasn't necessary to the story
it's probably my least favorite part of
the filmmaking process while
simultaneously being my favorite part
because it's really really hard but when
it works just makes me really happy so
after about a month of editing Ciaran
graded the film made it look more
cinematic
the 302 Brian composed all of the
original music
and then you watched it and said nice
things about it
so thank you after we were done with the
filming Kiran asked me how I was feeling
about the whole thing and I said that I
think this is gonna be the best thing
I've ever made and I also don't think
I'm gonna be completely happy with it
ultimately for me the point of me doing
these five short films is that I just
want to practice I just want to get
better and I want to know that I still
have room for improvement and so
although I am definitely proud of the
tea chronicles at the same time it's my
first short film and so I want to think
that I can do better now I'm going to
edit this and then get on to writing the
second short film which is a disaster
survival movie about the internet so
though I'm writing with my friend a
column who's Irish and he has lots of
hair so exciting that's it you've just
had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool would you like some
more tea would you like some more tea
does it like some more tea would you
like some more tea would you like some
more tea